hello everyone
this talk is on vertex fall tolerant
emulators and it's a joint work with
greg budman and mike dennis
let me start by defining a spanner
given a graph g we say that a sub graph
h of g is a t spanner
if for all nodes u and v
the distance between u and v in
the sub graph is at most t times their
distance in the original graph
so our goal is often to have a sparse
sub graph
that approximately preserve the
distances in the original graph so for
example here in the left we have this
dense graph and on the right hand side
we have a three spanner of it there's
parser and between every pair of notes
the distance is three times the distance
in g
now what is an emulator
it is similar to a spanner
but
it does not have to be a sub graph
so in particular again for every pair of
nodes we want the distance to be at most
t times the distance in g
in the emulator and we also
don't want to underestimate the distance
for any pair of nodes
so for example here you see that we are
given a graph g
and here we have a three emulator of g
and note that even if g is unweighted
the emulator often needs to be weighted
and now
h contains some edges that don't exist
in g
and it's easy to verify that between
every pair of notes there's a path that
is
at most three times the distance between
the endpoints in g
so the main question in the context of
spanners and emulators is
that given a parameter t
we want to know what is the minimum
number of edges needed
for
a t-spanner or
emulator for a graph
of size n in the worst case
and there are some existential bounds
known uh in particular for ndk at least
two
we know that there are um that any graph
has a 2k minus one spanner with roughly
n to the one plus one over k edges
and that this is optimal assuming the
eros gear conjecture
and i'll explain more about this
conjecture later
but moreover
there's
some equivalence between spanners and
emulators
in a sense that
even though we have more flexibility
with
emulators
this does not give us a better stretch
and size trade-offs in classical
settings
and
basically the size we would get would
not be any better for emulators
but
one message of this talk is that in the
fall tolerance settings this equivalence
no longer holds
and in particular
we can construct fault tolerant
emulators
that are sparser than
the equivalent
spanners and before i tell you what all
this means
let me define what a fault tolerant
spanner or emulator is
and
let me start by some motivation so
spanners are usually used in distributed
computing and networks
um
and
the goal is usually to
make to have a sparse subgraph that can
be used for the purposes of
communication or routing
for example here let's say i want to
construct the three spanner of this
network
and
now in practical settings uh
nodes in a network may fail
now the problem is if this was the
spanner reconstructed and now onenote
fails
our spanner is no longer useful because
basically these two parts of the graph
are not even connected anymore
um so
it makes a lot of sense in a lot of
practical situations to construct
spanners
that can tolerate a certain number of
failures
and in particular vertex
failures in
this stock
specifically
a graph or a sub graph
depending on whether we're talking about
an emulator or a spanner
for g
is f vertex fault tolerant
for parameter t
if for every possible fault set f of
size small f
after removing this
fault set f from
h
we still have a t emulator or a t
spanner of g minus f
and
in non-faulty settings we
know the optimal
size and stretch write-offs
but our goal here is to see
how
does the size of the emulator or the
spanner depend on this parameter f
and
the other question that we need to
answer is
um how do we set the weights of the
emulator edges that
are not in g so for spanners it's very
clear we're just maintaining a sub graph
but um
for emulators we are potentially adding
some new edges
and the question is what weight do we
give them
and um
let's see what our possibilities are and
what makes sense to be the weight of the
emulator edges
so remember that
the goal is to make sure that this holds
that for
any
edge
the distance between the endpoints
should be at most
t times the distance in g minus f
so
what are our options
in a lot of classical algorithms for
emulators we
always set the weight between a pair of
nodes u and v
to be
the distance between u and v in the
original graph
so let's say we do this
without taking any faults into account
and we just
set
the weight of an edge uv to be exactly
the
sub guv
but the problem is in this case any
fault set that changes the distance
between the u and v
is going to
uh cause a correctness problem
uh because in g minus f we're going to
get an underestimate of the distances if
we
keep the distances to be fixed
um
okay so
this doesn't quite work
so the other option is
to basically allow for the distance to
um
for the weight to change after falls
what i mean by that is consider a
uv edge that
is an emulator edge that wasn't in g
and now consider fault set f
and
we define the weight of this edge to
become the distance in g minus f so we
basically update the weight after the
falls happen
to be the shortest path
and
if you think about it for a minute this
is really the only natural option
because as we discussed if we set the
weight to be a fixed weight
it could violate the correctness um
as soon as
falls happen later
and we also
can't set it to be a smaller
weight than the distance after faults
because again this will cause a
correctness issue it will lead to
underestimates
it also doesn't help us to set it to be
a weight larger than
the distance after faults
because there's no existential benefit
and if for some reason for computational
reasons
we knew we do this to get more efficient
algorithms or something we can still
adapt our analysis
okay so
this is our definition of
fall tolerant emulators
that we can update the weights after
faults
okay so
let me also give you a practical
motivation for this definition
so what emulators really are in the
context of networks and distributed
systems are
what is known as oberlin and an overlay
network
um what is an overlay network um it's a
set of logical or virtual links between
nodes in a network
um and in the context of um
routing
um
these are basically
exactly like emulators uh in many
scenarios so let me give you an example
of how this logical links work for
routing
so let's say
i want to route a packet between node e
and node g in this network and there is
this
logical link or an emulator edge between
these two nodes
so
what the
routing protocols would do is they would
basically send the packet along the
shortest path between these two nodes
so what really happens in practice is
that
the application specific writing
protocols really send the data along um
the shortest path between
endpoints of a logical link
and they would do this
automatically after false
and this is exactly what an automatic
weight updating would do
and basically the quality of the routing
would depend on
the stretch or the quality of emulator
or this logical network that we've
constructed
so
this
weight updating
even though it may seem
kind of
new and strange
it makes sense both theoretically and
practically
okay now we've given
uh a definition of uh regular definition
of emulators uh in fall to learn
settings and
let's move on to an algorithm for
contracting emulators and what our
results are
so as i promised
we see that we can construct better
emulators
in fault tolerance
settings than we can construct spanners
and
our results and comparison between
emulators and spanners is
summarized here so what we know for fall
tolerance spanners by now is that
we can basically get
an optimal size for alternate spanner
of a
size roughly enter one plus one over k
times f to the one minus one over k
um
where f is um the
size of the
possible fault sets
and what we show is that for emulators
we can at least improve this
size
up to
square root f
for my k
and for rk we go further and um
get a bound that basically matches a
lower bound that we also show
so
uh
we basically get an emulator with
this size with respect to f which is
optimal for rk
so of course the first question that
comes to mind is what's going on with
this odd even um
difference
um
questions is it an inherent difference
because uh it also appears in the
context context of edge fault tolerance
spanners
and by edge filters
as the name suggests instead of vertices
edges can fail
another thing to note here is that our
goal is to
optimize the dependence on
f
but
in our algorithms the dependence on k is
not great and in particular it's
exponential in k
so another question is how can we
eliminate this dependence
uh but
interestingly for additive emulators
we get even um
more surprising improvement
in the fault tolerant case and in
particular we get additive emulators
that are exponentially better in size
than their spanner counterparts
and
this is because we
know no lower bound
for
f
vertex fault tolerant
additive spanners with additive
error c
for any constant c
and the way you can interpret this is
that for example for uh any uh set of
faults of at least size log n
we need n square
edges so
there's no hope of sparsifying
and getting an additive
approximation
but
in
the context of fault tolerant emulators
we show that we can get
optimal algorithms for plus two and plus
four emulators that are
exponentially better with respect to
this dependence on f
and you see the bounds here and
algorithms are pretty simple
but
the important takeaway is the message
that
we can do things for fall tolerant
emulators that we can't for
spanners
okay so let's move on to algorithms next
um
so let me start by a non-fault
tolerance algorithm for constructing
spanners it's a well-known algorithm
called the greedy algorithm and then
i'll explain how we extend it to the
faulty case
so this algorithm is pretty simple and
it's existentially optimal and this is
how it works
um we're given a graph g and a parameter
k
and
we start with an empty spanner h
and then in non-decreasing
order of
weight v process edges
and
for each edge uv
we'll look and see if between you and me
there's already a path that has length
at most 2k minus 1 w u v
so
if that's the case then we don't need
this edge so we will ignore it
otherwise we add this edge
and if you have an embedded graph the
ordering of edges being processed can be
arbitrary so
let's see a simple example
let's say we want to construct a 3
spanner
and
this is a graph we have
so we start with an empty graph
now between b1 and v2 um
there's
not already a path
so
we need to include this edge in the
spanner
we want to be three we don't already
have a path of length three so we
include it
same between three b4 but uh when we get
to v2 v4 there already exists a path of
length three
so we don't need to add this edge
this edge
and same with v2 v3 so
we have a simple tree spanner for this
graph
so
very briefly
it is easy to see why this algorithm is
correct
in a sense that
every edge that we don't add
it's because there's already a path of
length
2k minus one
um
let's say
we're looking at an invader graph uh
there's already a pad of like two k
minus one there and for any shortest
path we can just look at all of these
paths together and we get a two k minus
one um stretch guarantee
i won't get into the details but um the
size analysis is also based on the fact
that this graph doesn't have any small
cycles and we can
uh
argue that
a graphic no small a cycle
has at most into the oneplus one over k
edges
but let me go to the faulty setting
and
let's see how we can change the
algorithm to make it fall tolerant this
algorithm was first proposed by um both
v net alexa
2018
and
it's the same as the algorithm described
we again process the edges in the
non-decreasing weight order
but the difference is here when we
consider an suv we need to check and see
if there's any fault set f of size at
most f
that basically forces us to
add this edge
so is there any faults at f
such that the distance after we remove
uh
the nodes in f
becomes larger than 2k minus 1 times the
weight of uv
if there exists a default set then we
add uh
huv to the spanner
so clearly um
we are adding
um more edges because this fault set is
um forcing us to add more edges
okay now this was a algorithm for
spanner so
what do we do to turn it into an
emulator algorithm
as discussed we should somehow utilize
the fact that emulators give us some
more flexibility because we can add new
edges somewhere in the algorithm
so
the other thing to remember is that uh
the weights of these edges that we add
that didn't exist in g can also be
updated after faults
and
um i'm going to give you an algorithm
for five emulator because the general
algorithm is much more involved and it
requires new definitions so
i won't get into it
and the idea here is that whenever we
add a spanner edge uv
in the greedy algorithm
we also sample a set of emulator edges
like the edges that
are potentially not there
corresponding to three pads that have uv
as a
middle edge and in a weighted case uv
has to be the heaviest edge on this path
but
don't worry about those technicalities
um so here's
how the algorithm looks like
same as before we start with
an empty
subgraph
and
we have
a
parameter d that depends on f
and now for
again we go through edges
in on decreasing weight order and we see
if
for an edge uv there exists a fault set
that forces us to add this edge
um
and
if we add an edge uv
then in addition to uv we add a
sampled set of emulator edges
as follows we look at neighbors
of u
for example s
and
neighbors of v for example t we consider
such st
pairs
and
we add an emulator edge between s and t
with probability one over d squared
so this is really what is different in
the emulator algorithm with the spanner
algorithm
and
you will see that it will be helpful to
consider two type of edges in each the
spanner edges which are the edges that
already exist in g and the emulator
edges which are these
new sampled edges
they kind of have different behaviors in
our algorithm as we will see
so um
this algorithm does something
counterintuitive
because in a sense we're saying um
whenever we're adding
spanner edges uv
we're
going to add emulator edges in the same
vicinity
but intuitively
this helps us because
these additional emulator edges that
we're adding kind of help us reduce
adding more spanner edges later
and also
in
uh
in in case of f fault tolerant spanners
what we really want is
uh
to make sure that we aren't adding more
than roughly f pads between any pair of
nodes like you want to sparse a
graph that's what we should do we
shouldn't add more than
roughly f pads between any pairs
and
somehow
these emulator edges
along these three pads
will help us not add
too many
edges
so
very briefly correctness is again
easy
i won't get into it
the size analysis is more complicated
and
the idea is that
remember
we are
adding this emulator edges based on the
sampling probability
and somehow
um
the way this
sampling works is that
we can
ensure that for any pair of nodes s and
t
there's a
roughly
um
f
three pads that we are sampling from
and
uh
we can
use this process to charge
the emulator edges added to the spanner
i just added so in our analysis
uh
we can
bound the number of emulator edges that
are being added based on the number of
spanner edges that are being added
and then the path counting um
like we count the number of three paths
that we could sample from
and
somehow we can
use this to bound the number of spanner
edges and
hence
the number of corresponding emulator
edges
so
of course we
wanted to also give an algorithm for
general k i won't get into details of it
because it's more complicated we have to
define certain
set of paths
with certain properties
and then
the sampling proper
probability will depend on the length of
these pads
um
i
skip this
algorithm for this talk
but let me
finish by
some remarks on lower bounds and
polynomial time construction
so
i briefly mentioned the erdos gert
conjecture
which was
saying for any
integer k um there are graphs
with
girth at least two k plus two
and uh
at least n to the one plus one over k
edges
so this is a well-known conjecture
um and it's proven for some values of k
but using this conjecture we turn it
into
a lower bound for
constructing k emulators
2k minus 1 emulators
and basically
show that
we need at least roughly this many edges
and
the
instance is not very important but
at a high level we start with a girth
conjecture graph and we do some
transformation in particular we replace
each edge with a bipartite graph of
roughly size square root f
and then uh we have to reason that um
emulator edges can only replace a
constant number of spanner edges
uh so more or less the overall number of
edges we have to keep in this instance
is around
the original number of edges
which was
which gives us this point
finally the other thing to note is that
the algorithm i gave you takes
exponential time because for each edge
uv
we need to check
into the f possible fault sets
when we decide whether to add the edge
and
this is exponential in f so this is not
desirable
and to make this algorithm polynomial
time we use ideas
by
linux and robo which basically
lead to a polynomial time algorithm at
some additional factors of k in the size
and at a very high level the idea is to
replace this
entity f time procedure with
an algorithm that approximates the
smallest faults that f that
causes the distances to
go above the threshold
um and this approximation
algorithm is what
adds some additional factor in size
okay let me conclude
i described an algorithm for
constructing vertex fault tolerant
emulators
and also
uh
mentioned a matching lower bound with
respect to faults as a
file size f
but
this lower bound
matches the upper bound only when k is
odd
so the first open question
um is
can we close this gap for even k
and as i mentioned before this is also
on resolve for spanners um but for edge
fault tolerant case so maybe we should
answer it there first
the other natural question is
what happens if we
consider
edge failures instead of vertex failures
can we
get a better
size dependence on the number of
failures in that case
and
the other question is can we improve the
dependence on k in the size
and finally another question is
what can we do uh
for
other related objects like can we use
similar ideas to construct
say a fault tolerant distance oracles
or
other objects that are related
and with that
i finish this talk and thank you please
contact me with any questions you might
have